welcome everybody I made it
um it was really really uh touch and go
there for a little bit I wasn't sure if
I was going to be able to stream I don't
even think I have the right level on my
mic
but
um I made it I made it and I am remote
uh I have stories already to talk about
and let's just go through a few things
just to make sure we're going to be sort
of ready for this one it starts am I
coming in a little hot oh let me get
away hold on
is this any better
yeah I'm backlit I mean everything is
backwards let's just see if we have
audio here on the Trump stream we're
impacted well what's going on and of
course that's one of the biggest issues
right now in this country is what's
going down at the border and of course
Kamala Harris blaming everything that's
going on right now on they still can't
pronounce her name okay all right good
it seems like we have everything more or
less working
um now let's see where to even where to
even start
um
as far as I know we should be able to
see
super chats sometimes when I'm remote
I'm unable to say there it is okay good
yeah I'm limited by the number of
monitors when I'm remote and I figured
out a way even without me seeing it on
the screen I'm seeing there that it says
I mean it's sad what it says no new
super chats oh people saying my volume
is low let me turn myself up a little
bit
testing testing one two one two one two
is that any better
everything's fine okay good yeah I'll
just give myself a little more gain uh
we're standing by for a trump rally now
what is the point of the Trump rally I
don't know
um we're just gonna have to wait and see
and there are a ton of people watching
this on the right side broadcasting
stream 55 000 right now they have super
chats pouring in like high pressure
water I mean it's crazy crazy what's
going on
and
um
no it's not my laptop mic picking me
it's it's this right here
see that's what it is I can turn it up
if people want it turned up but we're
working all out no I'm not using my
laptop mic guys
not my laptop
see yeah I mean I can keep going up
I can keep going up if we need to Let's
also see if I can adjust my camera just
a little bit here
there we go we're learning as we go
we're learning as we go okay good so
we'll be able to see super chats as they
come in
what else do I have today that is
important
um oh I let's I'm gonna let's do a test
of whether I can update the number when
people sign up so Lefty oil can Astro
lycos and Caspa just signed up we're
changing it to three
and it worked okay good
so that worked
yeah it's just a little bit of an echoey
room you know as some of you know I'm
here in uh the state of Florida
and yesterday when I was uh I got on the
plane and they came over they said sir
are are you going to Florida and I said
no I thought I was going to Florida and
they said this is not the right plane
for you then
um and then I switched planes and then I
made it so that was all good but in all
that's a joke but in all complete and
total seriousness
the second I got off the plane and into
a lift
uh I mentioned to the lift guy you know
um there's a lot of people coming to the
area to get vaccinated because Florida's
vaccinating anybody
and the guy immediately says and I
tweeted about this yesterday
um I'm not I'm not getting vaccinated I
said really why why not he said no my
mom got it and she became magnetic
and I said uh sir are you sure and he
said yeah no it's for real and I said
you know I think it's just sweat and
he's like no no I don't the a key sticks
to her only on the side she was
vaccinated to which I said
um keys aren't typically magnetic and he
said well no some are some are not and
then at that point I said um
nothing else I changed the subject
because I was worried
it would go a different different
direction needless to say this guy's
personality was not exactly magnetic if
you know what I mean
so that's all that's all happening
oh super chats are coming in let's see
here sir thank you for oh hold on I need
to actually make sure I can see the
super chats here they are sir thank you
for the Saturday post
there goes the Crowder train you can
hear it now oh let's see if I can scroll
down a little bit
oh I can't see this last one
I guess I'm not able to see the last
soup J Bundy's Super Chat won't go
people I guess will have to be working
together
um
until another Super Chat comes in I
guess I can't see that one sorry jay
really weird
let's take a listen and see what's going
on here
I take her whenever I can she's awesome
all right so if you don't know who I am
I'm the guy that uh Mr Lindell
discovered and has been featuring in his
movies whoa that's a note that's gonna
be a no for me dog
um that's not uh
that's not that's not interesting to me
okay
so I think we're basically in good shape
the TV is too loud you guys mean this
audio Frank speech or on Lindell TV and
no Frank is not named after me
it it means is that the old truthful
conversation we're gonna have Frank talk
yes
okay all right so that's going on this
is a day I've waited for right side
broadcasting network is my go-to for
Maga Nation glad to see Pac-Man lurking
on my guilty pleasure wow I can't tell
if that's a joke Jay or not
um
sir I am so sorry you have to be here in
Florida with all the trumpeters but
thank you for a well-balanced and
rational show you're the best thank you
I appreciate that
um
really appreciate that we are Just for
kicks we are doing a one day coupon code
sad Trump and it's sort of like you
can't help but feel a little bit bad for
the guy because this is all extremely
pathetic so today this is a previously
unpublished and
soon to be deleted coupon code at
joinpakman.com sad Trump all one word
all lower case and uh I apologize about
my echo it's also kind of a low quality
mic but I know I'm not supposed to
insult the Blue Yeti there's people
doing professional podcasts with a Blue
Yeti but it's just not for me
um sad Trump is the coupon code and it's
it's a today only sort of thing and I
don't even actually know
if I can easily access oh no I can oh
okay okay very good so for example let's
see here Chris reichelt just signed up
with the coupon code
and also Daniel Russell just signed up
with the coupon code so I think
everything's basically working I can set
that to five and then our little um
our little thing here is now we're I was
skeptical that all of this stuff was
going to work
but it is all working as we stand by for
Donald Trump about 39 minutes from now
and I I just have no I it's impossible
to prepare for this because I don't know
what
um the point of the rally even is is it
to say he won is it to make some kind of
announcement I really don't know what it
is that uh
what the point of this entire thing is
but we're going to watch it together we
will be standing back we will be
standing by and it's all going to be
very exciting I also want to say
um
oh there's there's people getting banned
again oh to ask for donations yeah maybe
this is all to ask for donations for
Trump that's certainly a possibility I
would not put it uh would not put it
past just doing a fundraising event for
sure
okay very good other super chats let's
look at what else we've got here
um
you've kept me company during my
dissertation work appreciate that do you
think those that voted against
certification is a argument to Mitch
saying there is no need for federal
action on voting that I'm that I'm sure
about
that I'm not sure about
Robert says love you David hope you can
see this you sound like you have a cold
my son and I are both fully vacced and
we're both getting over a cold now this
is just a much lower quality microphone
than I'm used to using and I I don't
think I could possibly be in a more
echoey room
um
I I said please give me a a room that is
not echoey
and they said sir we've got the echoist
room uh people are studying this room to
know how it becomes so echoey and I said
no no I think you guys misunderstood
Carlos Payne says why is everyone
talking about critical race Theory I
I've done so many segments on that I
don't want to dig into that too much
right now
Megan says I love the interview with Dr
alok canoja interview more psychiatrists
welcome to Florida we aren't all crazy
Katie says love the Pac-Man live streams
Daniel says today is to announce the
health care plan I like that if you guys
remember in July of 2020 Trump said we
were two weeks from him announcing his
health care plan
he's ready to do it he's going to
announce it today
fulcrum says welcome to Florida David if
you're in the Tampa area there's a cat
I'm not no I'm not in that area